Now the coding solution is fantastic for a single file, but practical usage
fails. Once we want to load a suite of files, we effectively need to specify a
callback for each one of them. Instead, we should add support to our asset
manager to allow us to pass a list of files to load. And receive one callback
once they've all been loaded. So what we'd like you to do, is modify the load
assets function to taking a list of asset names in a single callback function.
Now just as a heads up, this process may be a little bit tricky. You'll
probably want to do something right here in the onload function to keep track
of how many files have been loaded so far. Make note of it, so that you only
have to issue one callback function. One other interesting aspect that you're
going to have to change is what if all of the assets are loaded, or what if
some sub-portion of them are loaded and other ones need to be loaded? In this
situation make sure you also take into account, what happens if half of the
images are loaded, or none of the images are loaded, or all of the images are
loaded? In these three different scenarios you should have a different logic
path on when the callback function actually gets issued. So for example if all
of the assets are loaded, you may only need to do one callback function
immediately.